the space race pitted Moscow against
Washington for decades but now it's
bringing more than just two countries
closer it's a relationship that's
proving a catalyst for learning together
as Russia breathes new life into a
cutting edge launch site in the middle
of the ocean
[Music]
it's maiden mission was in 1999 since
then 36 launches 32 of them successful
rockets flown from sea launch were
produced in Ukraine and equipped with a
Russian made engine after 2014 launches
from the pad were indefinitely canned as
relations between the countries hit rock
bottom
s7 space the company that starts itself
with reviving the platform plans on
bringing it to the shores of Russia's
Far East next year and it will take
another 12 months to get it operational
it is expected Sea Launch will continue
to fly Ukraine made rockets until 2023
when it is scheduled to make a switch to
soyuz 5 a Russian rocket still in
development
everything from the Pacific Ocean the
man steering a seven space is no
stranger to orbital exploration his
military background makes him ambitious
so much so he's being dubbed the Russian
Elon Musk
but vladislav Phillips says there's a
key difference between Musk he's a
talented guy but mr. musk is always
trying to sell the future while here in
Russia we're living in our current
economic reality and sell exactly what
we have now there's tough competition
before as7 space to become number one in
the industry but Russia's government has
already said it will aid its cause
Vladislav field of is a big space
enthusiasts it is in his blood I hope
the project will last for a long time I
will offer to cooperate fully with him
we are interested in supporting private
Russian companies and we are ready to
share risks now it's too early to say
with confidence if SpaceX has reason to
worry but there's a new team with a big
vision
you